- [Lecturer] Al is comparing
two recipes for homemade bread.
The recipe for white bread calls for
4/10 of a kilogram of flour.
The recipe for whole wheat bread
calls for 385/1000 of a kilogram of flour.
Which bread takes less flour?
So the white bread calls
for 4/10 of a kilogram,
while the recipe of whole
wheat bread calls for
0.385 kilograms, or
385/1000 of a kilogram.
Now the way I wrote it is important.
You always want to line up the decimals
when you are comparing,
because you want to
compare numbers in the same place value.
And this is an interesting
example of even though
the number down here has
more digits it doesn't mean
that it's necessarily a larger number.
What we want to do when we compare numbers
and this is true whether we're
dealing with decimals or not,
is we start in the largest place value.
We could start in the ones place,
'cause both of these have zero ones.
Then we go one place value
down, we go to the tenths place.
The white bread, it requires 4/10 of flour
while in the whole wheat bread
we only have 3/10 of flour.
So we can stop right there.
This has more tenths than this does.
It doesn't matter that this has more
hundredths and thousandths.
Those are less significant.
They don't add up to as much
as what we're dealing with
when we look just at the tenths place.
So because four is greater than three,
and we're in the tenths place
we know that white bread
takes more flour, but we
have to be very careful.
They said which bread takes less flour?
So it's going to be whole wheat bread.
Three is less than four.
Let's do another one of these.
A group of fifth graders kept track
of the number of hours they spent
working on their science project right?
Put the students in order from the
least to greatest amount of time spent.
The student with the least amount of time
should be at the top of the list.
So pause this video and
see if you can do this.
And this is actually a screenshot
from the Khan Academy exercise.
If you're doing the Khan Academy exercise
you'd actually be able to click on these
and move them around.
But let's compare them.
So as I mentioned in the last example,
when you're comparing numbers it's good
to line up the place
values, so let's do that.
So Adam is 5.5.
Aviv is five, and Jenny is 5.17.
So once again, start at
the largest place value.
Start at the ones.
They all have exactly five ones,
so then we move to the next place value.
In this case, we're going
to go to the tenths place.
So when we look at the tenths place,
interesting things are going on.
Aviv has no tenths.
It's a blank here, but
you could do this as 5.0.
So Aviv has the fewest tenths, then comes
Jenny with only 1/10
and then Adam has 5/10.
So that tells us enough so
that we can order the three.
We don't even have to look
at the hundredths place
because the tenths here are different.
So the least number of tenths is Aviv,
so that's going to be Aviv is the least.
They all have the same number of ones,
but Aviv has the least tenths.
Then comes Jenny.
Jenny, once again, they all
have the same number of ones
but then Jenny has less tenths than Adam,
and then comes Adam.
Adam has the most tenths.
It doesn't matter that
Jenny also has 7/100.
Notice you could view this as 17/100
which is going to be less than 5/10
which could also be viewed as 50/100.
So the general way to think about it,
start at the most significant,
the largest place value, compare.
If things are equal, go
to the next place value.
When things are different, then you have
enough information to start ordering them.